it was hard getting a ticket yeah I bet
um I had to enter a lottery to get a
ticket and then I got a ticket but it
was assigned to and even doing that was
a nightmare that was I'm underselling
how hard this was it's very [__]
difficult it's such a pain in the ass
and you need a Japanese phone number
yeah um so if you have a foreign phone
number you which wouldn't accept it um
and it was tied to your ID which is's a
thing apparently in Japan they do this
where concert tickets are tied to your
ID and when you go in I thought okay
well that's okay they they won't check
it it won't be important but no they
checked at the door that the your ID
matched with your ticket yeah it's
supposed it's supposed to stop
scalers um So I entered this Lottery
paid $140 to enter this Lottery to get a
ticket and I got a ticket and then I
went to pog Champs in America in August
at some time yep and L was coming and it
happened to be where the day after uh
the RV stream ended yeah it was that was
the concert and I remember I I brought
it up to lwi and then I found afterwards
it was like his favorite song was by y
and so I was like oh okay well I'll try
and get you a ticket no promises um and
I I just couldn't get him a ticket like
I entered the the lottery again couldn't
get one entered the cancellation thing
again couldn't get one and then he was
like you bastard you betrayed me how
dare you go without me I was like dude
what do you I can't do anything I I
could buy listen if if this isn't
America money can't fix every problem
you you just lose a lottery and that's
life here yeah everything gotcha yeah
how was the concert though dude it was
insane yeah I [__] B jeal the best
concert I think I've ever been to oh
[__] I thought cuz the man was like 70
that it would he would sound older cuz
he did all these songs like 40 years ago
yeah I thought oh maybe he's getting old
now and he can't do it bro no bro hadn't
lost a single bit it was crazy it was 3
hours is that is that am I crazy that's
long of just him singing that's long no
no
no normally a set is like an hour and a
half two hours maybe it was just 3 hours
uh and I asked people I was like is
there like a supporting thing for like
what time should I go and they're like
no no no in Japan there's no supporting
acts I just like to think it was
actually Yar story just being like
listen I have too many bangers um I
can't cut any I think so I I think he
just has so many good songs that it was
impossible like cuz even some of the
songs that I really liked like uh
someday didn't get played and I was like
what the [__] someday is like a banger
yeah it is um yeah I've I've grown a new
appreciation for you know singers
especially in concerts that do a really
really long set after doing our own yeah
after like doing our own show which is 2
hours and sometimes just [__] somehow
arguing about bread on stage for a good
one segment of our show my voice is like
I could feel the tiredness in My Voice
by the end of this show and I'm like
what [__] singers do it by themselves
for Two Plus hours crazy God godam it's
almost like they go through vocal
training okay there Joey insane I know
I'm sure you some of you might know his
music right on time uh what else uh I'm
I'm blank now Morning Glory what's that
what's that one s what's what's that one
um it's shine sh is myor great one he
did the Christmas one that's really
popular as well everyone knows the song
in Japan it was just really good but it
was like it was kind of nuts I've never
been in a I've thought Man 3 hours a
long time and I will admit an hour and a
half in I was like kind of dozing out at
one point cuz I was like but it was like
it was like a really long song like a
ballad I don't really care about his
ballad songs that much because I'm a
fake fan um it was like n it was like 9
minute song and there's what dude it was
it was so weird cuz like I've never been
to a concert where he was just like I
don't know if he was ad living or what
like halfway through his songs he would
just start ad living yeah in a really
cool way it was really really fun um uh
and and there was so many points where
he would just be like all right sack
solo time for like a minute and the dude
would go for a sack solo and it was just
so [__] hype yeah would just tear it
up for a minute that's that's a real
artist when you can like switch sh up
from like the studio version and it
slaps just as hard if not sometimes
harder yeah cuz like every I think half
the songs at some point he would just go
on like a riff or do something else that
was really cool I was like oh my God
this is extended solos and [__] yeah
they had like a whole like a set that
was moving as well and like light up it
was really cool um and yeah there dude
it was just so cool I just like
especially right on time right on time
was so good cuz it was like oh he went
off stage he didn't sing it then he came
back and everyone was like oh my God
obviously was gonna happen how big was
this concert like was it pretty big or
was low 4,000 capacity oh yeah that's
big um it was really strange cuz it was
like no one it was like I think also I
saw an article that was like he had
shouted at someone mid song and stopped
singing because they was they were like
singing along in the audience like shut
the [__] up this is my song this is my
moment so it's it's like picture it it's
like the most biggest bangers of your
life yeah dead silent no one has
no one's allowed to move no one is
allowed to dance no one is allowed to
take pictures which I agree with but
like no one is allowed to do anything
until you are signal to clap and then
you can start everyone can clap together
like this and then finally like two hour
two and a half hours in they finally let
you all stand up and then everyone kind
of starts doing like that kind of like
half dance for they oh like the aunt at
a wedding dance because dude I rock up
to this concert everyone's 60 oh yeah oh
okay everyone is old uh no other
foreigners as well I couldn't find a
single other Foreigner it was just me
surrounded by a bunch of old people
which I was happy with yeah it was just
it was very interesting cuz I felt like
it was when you watch those like North
Korean crowds kind of felt like that
where it was like we were not allowed to
express anything until you are told to
start clapping and singing like that's
that's a big ask for that kind of music
as well right cuz it was like like when
we went to the cigar concert right it
makes sense that we were like sitting
and still because that was the vibe of
the music
ifel if How it Go sense but like y music
is made for singing and dancing too so
the fact that they were like uh yeah so
enjoy the concert by the way you're not
allowed to express any fun whatsoever
until we tell you to it's a bit weird
yeah it was that was the only thing that
I kind of I guess I mean I guess for
other some other people they maybe in
Japan as well they appreciate that they
can just have that like experience not
having to worry about any other like
sensor sensory like distractions I mean
sure but there was one Japanese dude one
Brave man down in the front he was just
going like full like like Colton dance
in the front like he was going crazy
like and no one else was dancing and I
was like the balls on this man to do it
I I respect it I respect it hell yeah
dude it was such an amazing I've already
decided because apparently he does it
every single year he does like a four
four Monon long uh tour every single
year in Japan so I'm definitely going
back if he does it again I we should all
try and go next year oh fun fact you
can't buy tickets in more than groups of
two oh awesome so if you you can only
apply in groups of two oh sorry G you're
going to have to stay behind so let's
say so we could all apply as groups of
two but if one of the you wins Lottery
the other
group like me and Joey might get tickets
we might not or we all might get tickets
and we cannot sit next to each other me
and Joey will be next to each other but
you won't be next yeah this is like
insane like I just don't understand how
there's not a better way that's that's
weird because every concert I've been to
in Japan where it's like a lottery
system it's always the max is always
four really this one was two that's
weird I've never heard of I fig saying
I'm saying when I when I applied for
Taylor Swift tickets which I'm I'm
seeing Taylor Swift in February by the
way in uh in Japan by the way which is
like out of left field but uh did it cuz
uh Sydney's mom is like a massive you
Lottery huh you enter the lottery yeah
we had to enter the lottery and somehow
we won on like Taylor Swift tickets as
well you can Al like Mass purchase
lotteries but problem is if you win all
like four or five you you you already
paid the deposits they just take your
money yeah so it's a it's a huge G so
that's when you have to like start
ringing up people being like hey I got
tickets you want the thing though if you
that that's why I didn't get any extra
tickets cuz you had to sign everyone up
with the full IDs and mobile numbers and
if you won on that lottery ticket with
that ID you were not allowed to change
it that ISD which I I never heard of
that I hate that they did this because I
I feel like yes scalping is a huge issue
and there needs to be S done about it
and this is definitely one way of
combating it but this should also be an
probably a we can make it equally as
convoluted and complicated we can make
it impossible but there should be a way
that you can transfer the ticket if you
have a genuine reason to someone else
make it really really difficult so
scalping becomes a pain in the ass yeah
um cuz scalping is [__] [__] move
and that that needs to like I don't know
how you combat it without going through
this much but yeah but the fact that I
can't I have like three mates I can't go
to a concert and sit next to all of us
it's like [__] like that's I mean you
you sacrifice the experience and it's
because of the [__] scalpers at the
end of the day
unfortunately um but I mean I I feel
like two is a little bit of a low number
should be at least four we've seen
America's America's method of combating
now they've made it so that if you make
over I think it sound like it wasn't a
lot it was like maybe a thousand or less
than $1,000 if you make over $1,000
selling tickets you get taxed quite a
lot okay now that being punished by the
IRS the ultimate the ultimate punishment
the ultimate Moon killer yeah they
realized that Ticket Master the enemy of
my enemy is my friend actually there
this one entity you can count on to like
to to smack down on a group of people
being [__] it's the tax man they just
they they come down uh Sometimes good
sometimes bad normally bad but
occasionally they ever win was that the
first concert you had ever been to in
Japan yeah I'd been to really small
concerts but they were all like friends
or it was never like a really big one
never a Japanese artist but I want to go
to more City pop ones it' be fun yeah
hell yeah like I want to go see hre live
that'd be fun or Mari uh teesa yeah
she's teesa now she's married toes uh
that'd be fun to watch she's got bangers
too yeah absolutely but I mean T's got
so many bangers back to back got so many
he's got to stop you you know some a
banger when when Connor is getting this
passionate about beeps and boops listen
to the cuz he we released the right on
time album and it's literally just like
all his bangers and it's just like 50
minutes of just non-stop bangers yeah
absolutely so good that that I've been
trying to get that vinyl for ages now
and like the cheapest I've found it for
was like
$500 wait oh the original they the
re-release one which came yeah but I
want the original that'd be impossible
yeah and I just can't find it and when I
have found it it's like would you like
to pay $2,000 for an LP I'm like also
mid song I guess this is a thing in
Japan uh he would he would just talk
about Bunch oh yeah that is a thing in
Japan they do a bunch of talking and uh
a bunch of people would laugh
occasionally but the one that got like
the biggest shock reaction I guess this
isend thing at one point he goes uh yes
I haven't drank in two years and
everyone
goes it's
like they never reacted the whole crowd
gasped and I've never seen anything like
this in some like some like con I've
been to in Japan with like a primarily
Japanese audience like when the artist
starts mcing and like there's an
audience reaction it just sounds like a
sitcom it was like mostly like laughs
and it wasy and uh CU he was talking
about like just how he's old that was
his main joke that he kept saying um and
he was like I don't know why people are
I don't know why there's young people
here I didn't listen to old people when
I was young he just called you
out he saw you and he was just like
didn't know foreigners were here as well
yeah yeah so and he's making fun of some
of the laws that Japan was trying to
make it was very I'm sure I'm sure if
they could if translate everyone go Bas
yeah very
Bas um that was very interesting I guess
it's the older demographic all people in
Japan all old people in Japan drink yeah
I think I've met a single person in
Japan over the age of 50 that doesn't
drink my granddad really damn he he
never drank damn it's so rare in Japan
but he smoked like
seven got
a choose one I reckon he's a he's
probably a stoner that was born in the
wrong
country I don't know about
wow he loved his malor that's for
sure yeah yeah I mean I I've only been
to a few concerts in Japan but they all
pretty much follow that formula
especially if it's a Japanese artist
it's very different from like the kind
kind of like they they always have a
story behind like every after every song
or preceding like every song about a
little monologue about something going
on in their lives when I wrote this song
I was 30 years old and I was at a
turning point in my life you know it's
it's always some [__] like that and I'm
just like that's cool and all but like
just you know it's it's it's fine like I
I I get the law and it's like it's
sentimental and it's cool and stuff like
that but it's like after a while you go
to enough concerts and it's like oh let
me guess yeah you wrote this song when
it was a turning point in your life all
right cool near the end of the show
there was like this merch presentation
live where like some guy kept handing
like like a like it was on an easel like
merch kept coming out on a stand it was
very funny it was very Japanese it was
and we have exhibit a merch number one
please go buy it and then he was just
it's very fun I I love like the the the
dichotomy between like a Japanese artist
in Japan and how they do their concerts
versus a western band or artist cuz like
you know cuz when I went to go see the
pillows it was very similar whereas like
you know like because it was it was also
like uh you know during like the
beginning of CO as well so it's like
you're not allowed to like cheer you're
not allowed to like take videos and
photos which is one that's very rare I'm
sure you weren't allowed to take videos
and photos no I I I want I wanted this
just take one little picture memor set
was so cool but there was a dude
literally right behind me he would he
would have me exactly and it's like and
you know there's always like some MC
segments and all that kind like it's
it's kind of formulaic andile like when
I went to go see like Bad Religion at
the punk spring uh there was a huge sign
at the beginning of their gig that was
just like uh no crowd surfing oh okay
you know and like no moshing there was
like two big signs that just like that
bad religion came out and they were like
[__] these signs start moshing start
crowd surfing right now [__] the police
oh my God and then immediately Japanese
people were like well I mean if they say
so three dudes start Crow suring I'm
just like there we go that's what's up
that's the way to go there go that's how
that's how you go to punk con it's not
in the contract like they just didn't
give a [__] meanwhile I'm I'm really
hoping that when I go see the Taylor
Swift concert that she does that thing
about when she introduces the song I
haven't seen it before until it started
blowing up on Tik Tok but she has like
this really cheesy kind of like
introduction to every song you know
those times when you see a boy and you
just think to yourself wow he's going to
be trouble and then trouble stop play
wait is that is that what she does
she sounds great every at the beginning
of every single Taylor Swift concert
she's like my name is Taylor Swift and I
was born in
1989 and everyone's
like is this real it's real there's so
many Tik toks of it it's so funny I did
not know how big of a deal T like I knew
she was a big deal but I did not know
how big of a deal it was to go to like
one of her live concerts until until
like we somehow managed to get tickets
you know for Sydney's mom's uh birthday
uh and only when I started telling
people they're like what you got ticket
you get to see Taylor Swift live cuz I I
saw there was an article that like when
she goes to a city to do a concert it
has like such a big economic effect on
that City it's almost like the Super
Bowl going to that city which well this
this current like uh tour that she's on
right now it's like spanning for like a
year and a half and it's considered to
be one of the biggest and most lucrative
tours ever in the music industry damn
like I can't imagine I just what what is
she doing man dude she's [__] Scrooge
MCD ducking like everything like she's
drowning I guess it's weird cuz I knew
she was really popular but it kind of
felt like just this year in particular
just became crazy yeah I don't know why
maybe the tour maybe it's for the tour
maybe it's the tour but it's it's also
cuz like Taylor Swift fans a are like
insane come on man don't disrespect them
call them swifties right swifties
swifties gu I guess you can talk about
this cuz Sydney's mom is the head of the
Swifty Council she is literally like the
head of the Swifty Council in her like
local area like you know you know how uh
basically you know how like most most
places have like a neighborhood watch or
something you know they the Swifty watch
they have the Swifty watch and she and
she basically runs that she was such a
big like Swifty that that there was like
some ticket controversy or some ticket
issues in like the America Tour that was
going on The Ticket Master The Ticket
Master thing uh and you know news uh
news outlets were doing reports in it
and uh one of the people they contacted
was Sydney's
mom and uh like live just now we have
the representative of the Swifty
Community here in Wisconsin it's just
Sydney's mom so you know Sydney's had
her 15 minutes of fame but she's never
been on national TV before as cuz her
mom's been now been on national tv as
Swifty so that is that is now her title
awesome but yeah it's it's like she
tells me stories about just like all of
like the Taylor Swift fans like
worldwide doing meetups and no matter
where she goes in the world she always
have she always has like people that she
can hit up because there are swifties
all over the world that she can kind of
do a Meetup with uh and I'm like this is
this is an insane Network right now it's
it's crazy it's like it's almost it's
dare I say almost
cultish it is a littleit it is kind of
scary you know when you like you know
cuz like personally like I think Taylor
swi just okay like she's made some hits
a lot of her stuff I think is just kind
of mid but like godamn if I said that to
a I'd be scared to say that to a Swifty
even if I know they might be cool with
me like which era did you listen to yeah
it's like oh yeah I like a couple of
songs and then be like name all of them
you know like I like I know that if I
you know went up to Sydney's mom and I
was just like you know full respect to
Taylor Swift um I just think she's okay
you know if I said anything else I know
Sydney's mom would be cool with it yeah
Sydney's mom is a lovely lovely person
she wouldn't say anything it would just
like she'd just probably die inside a
little bit I'm just jealous I wish I was
that passionate about something I am too
you know